colleen rooney set up a sting
investigation to make puaro proud a bid
to stop private details of her love life
being shared with the press giving
evidence for the first time she offered
context that in 2019 her marriage to
wayne was going through a rough patch
and all the time stories were being
leaked
the plot twist wagatha christie herself
couldn't have foreseen was that three
years on from that infamous instagram
post naming rebecca vardy as guilty
she'd be dragged to court over it rooney
said it had been a last resort and any
abuse vardy received was not intended
asked what she did to mitigate the
impact on her fellow wag who was then
receiving death threats and was so
stressed by the whole incident she said
she was scared she was going to lose her
baby colleen rooney pointed to a legal
letter that she received from rebecca
vardy's people she said her lawyers then
instructed her not to comment any
further
lawyers for vardy suggested rooney's
problem is actually with how the sun
treated her rather than the leak she
agreed that in 2019 when her family
moved to america so her husband could
play in the states the newspaper
targeted them on an almost weekly basis
crucially she told the court she
believed vardy's desire to be famous
made her untrustworthy she'd been told
by an fa liaison officer that vardy had
moved seats to get extra attention at
euro 2016.
rooney was questioned about a grid of
exclusives which she said she created to
show all the instagram stories vardy had
shared with the paper and which she
believed were based on her private
instagram posts
vardy's lawyer told rooney what she
believes is not relevant that there
isn't a shred of evidence to prove the
facts
colleen rooney says she tried to resolve
her libel battle with rebecca vardy on
three occasions in vain she said i've
been silent i don't want to be here it's
mrs vardy who has brought me here while
vardy told the court i didn't do
anything wrong i wanted to clear my name
and not just for me for my family and my
children
hundreds of thousands of pounds later
this case continues katie spencer sky
news